If you think America is ready for a
political and economic revolution, you
should consider why the rise of Bernie
Sanders isn't freaking out Wall Street.
The stock market keeps climbing
despite Bernie's status as a clear
front-runner for the Democratic
nomination. And given that he's a
self-described Democratic Socialist, many
on Wall Street think that a strong
economy will lead the Trump's reelection,
particularly if Sanders is the nominee.
Others know that even if Sanders manages
to win the White House, he'll have
difficulty enacting Medicare for All or
a wealth tax in Congress. He'll need
filibuster-proof majorities in the
Senate, or at least a majority where even
moderate Democrats are committed enough
to a health care proposal that gets more
unpopular the more people hear about it.
And even if Bernie succeeds in passing
these policies, Wall Street can still cast
its de facto vote. In 2008, a plummeting
Dow convinced Congress to reverse
course and pass the bank bailout. In 2021, a
similar reaction might give Congress
second thoughts about Bernie's war on
wealth. For these reasons, Wall Street doubts
that Bernie's people-powered revolution
will actually take place.
Should Wall
Street investors be concerned about a
Sanders presidency? Let us know in our
poll. Also, let us know what other topics
you'd like our scholars to cover in 60
seconds, and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI.